bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
des france comment décrire la situation
en birmanie depuis que la jante après
pouvoir en février il ya depuis le 1er
février en fait c'est une situation qui
ne s'arrange pas et qui prend des
tournures je dirais d'un conflit à la
syrienne mais si pau le mans c'est un
petit peu moins important en effet on a
d'une part des opposants mais qui sont
relativement mal organisé donc on a une
opposition qui est très forte dans le
pays on a d'autre part ce qui n'arrange
pas les choses que le peuple birman on a
une situation sanitaire qui est
catastrophique
et puis également une situation
économique quasiment à l'arrêt c'est à
dire que tous les progrès qu'ils avaient
été pu être constaté jusqu'à présent en
birmanie en matière de lutte contre la
pauvreté en matière de démocratie en
matière de gérer de meilleure qualité de
vie et bien sont à l'arrêt depuis que la
junte militaire est au pouvoir donc
depuis maintenant quelques mois et cette
jeune militaire avec des gérer des des
attentions envers ses promesses ou des
pseudo je dirais promesses de démocratie
en fait il n'en est rien actuellement le
pays semble se passer je dirais dans un
peu dans le chaos mais aux dépens du
peuple birman et sur le concernant le
mouvement de contestation est ce que
vous direz malgré tout qu'il reste fort
qu'il se renforce peut-être oui il se
renforce néanmoins la principale
préoccupation au gel et des paysans des
du peuple birman actuellement c'est
effectivement à la fois de retrouver le
jir et une démocratie meilleure vie mais
avant tout que la situation sanitaire
s'améliore alors qu'elles se dégradent
constamment et la birmanie a besoin je
dirais en premier lieu de médicaments de
vaccins
d'accès à toutes sortes de gérer de
technologie médicale que nous avons nous
en occident et que parfois même un bon
test malheureusement en tout cas que
vous bien avoir donc c'est un pays qui
tente de s'organiser dans une sorte de
jeu tiré de semis guerre civile avec une
opposition qui reste malheureusement
très divisés puisque la birmanie et est
assuré elle a beaucoup d'ennemis de
population de partis politiques
différents et la jeune militaire qui
elle même et par et désorganisée arrive
quand même à maintenir sans pouvoir sur
une population qui majoritairement
s'organisent pour sa survie mais restent
encore divisés en matière de combat ou
de manifestations est ce que ce
mouvement de protestation a une chance
de conduire à une forme d'un sous
plissement du côté de la gente militaire
il est difficile de le dire parce que je
ne connais pas je dirais les réactions
d'une jeune militaire c'est un petit peu
les caractéristiques d'un pouvoir fort
une dictature surtout lorsqu'elle est
menée d'une main de fer et sans aucun
cas l'avis de la population ou même de
ces cartes donc là on peut penser que la
junte militaire
pourrait céder sur tout devant la
pression internationale si elle est
appuyée effectivement par sa population
mais tout cela effectivement
malheureusement passera par des
manifestations de rue mais qui reste
encore très nombreux en birmanie le gros
riffs que je dis c'est vraiment là je
dirais le lancement dans un conflit qui
va reposer les civils d'une part et puis
une jeune militaire qui est puissante
mais qui a encore désorganisé donc on ne
sait pas trop encore ou lanvin et les
gérer les apparences de la démocratie
dans laquelle s'habille la junte
militaire et est vraiment une illusion
la plus totale est un retour sur le
devant de la scène dans sainte-sophie
vous semble envisageable bien écouter ce
serait en tout cas pour beaucoup de de
beer mort une solution parce que d'une
part elle a exercé le pouvoir et puis
elle est une figure internationale qui
est reconnu dans le monde entier en tant
que prix nobel de la paix et c'est là
toute la problématique de la junte
militaire qui voudrait bien l'écarter
mais qui ne peut la défaire de son image
internationale en la plaçant
régulièrement en résidence surveillée
donc la solution c'est effectivement une
pression internationale à la fois forte
mais souple pour aider le peuple birman
haut niveau je dirais de de l'appui
sanitaire et puis ce serait une alliance
internationale qui favorise enfin le
retour de la démocratie la fin de ces
dictatures militaires qui se succèdent
et que l'on retrouve une démocratie et
aussi pour le peuple birman une
meilleure économie et donc qu'elle n'a
pas pu également se porter mieux mais là
on en est pas encore ici vous évoquez la
pandémie en birmanie quelle est la
situation sanitaire précisément dans le
pays aujourd'hui bah écoutez c'est un
petit peu chaotique les legends et celle
de celles et brouillé par eux mêmes la
birmanie manque de vaccins la birmanie
man que je dirais de de grandir de l est
a été fermée comme bon nombre de pays au
niveau de ces aéroports au niveau de ses
frontières et aujourd'hui la junte
militaire semble avoir globalement
abandonné sa population à s'en sort
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage
pierre picard je n'appelle que vous êtes
géopolitologue spécialiste de l'asie